The first thing we see
in the app delegate is
application did finish
launching with options.
This happens immediately
after your app launches,
this might be a good time to set up
your core data stack but not to save.
After all there is nothing new
worth saving at this point.
Next we have application
will resign active.
This happens when the app's still in
the background but is no longer active.
Not being active means user input, such
as taps, don't reach the app anymore.
This happens when you're using the app
and you get a phone call, for example.
This is a good moment to save.
Next, we have application
did enter background.
This means your app has
been sent to the background
because the user
switched to another app.
This is also a good time to save.
Later on we have application
will enter foreground and
application did become active.
These mean that your app is
back from the background,
it wouldn't make much
sense to save in here.
And last but not least,
we have application will terminate.
Your app is about to
be killed by the OS.
Either the user closed the app or
iOS decided to shut it down,
this sounds like a good time to save but
actually isn't.
You don't have much time
left at this point.
You may want to do a print goodbye cruel
world, but anything else is risky.
Why not saving immediately
after creating a new note?
In this case it would be okay,
as our data model is very simple.
However, in a more complex app,
it's better not to overdo it and
save too often, unless you know
how to do it in the background.
We'll look at how to do that later.
So this was all very informative but
we still don't have a concrete answer.
If saving every time we change
something is too much saving and saving
only when the app goes to the background
or becomes inactive, it's too little.
What's the best solution?